hey everyone I'm Abby from Abby's
kitchen welcome back to our series in
lined by intuitive eating in our last
video we discussed principle six of
intuitive eating discover the
satisfaction factor so if you haven't
watched that video yet go check it out
and then come back to watch this one
now before I want to get started I do
want a flag that this content may not be
for all of my viewers so feel free to
take and leave what you find valuable
and don't forget to follow the intuitive
eating journey along with me through
Evelyn Triple E and Lise Russia's book
which I have linked below also a big
thank you to Alyssa Ramsey intuitive
eating dietitian who reviewed this video
I'm going to be leaving some links below
to her Instagram and website if you're
looking for some one-on-one support okay
now let's get into a reader question
dear abby i really want to practice
intuitive eating but I find myself
naturally eating a lower carb diet can I
still eat intuitively this way or do I
need to follow the recommended
macronutrient distributions that are
recommended by major health authorities
so great question there are official
guidelines for dietary macronutrients
distributions so it's recommended for
example that you get 45 to 65% of your
daily calories from carbs 20 to 35
percent of your daily calories from fat
and 10 to 35% of your calories from
protein this is a general guideline
based off of population research and is
known as the acceptable macronutrient
distribution range or the AMDR for short
so each macronutrient carbs fat protein
provides energy in the form of calories
now according to the AMD RS consuming
the macronutrients within the suggested
ranges is associated with reduced risk
of diseases while also providing enough
nutrients for good health
having said that keep in mind that these
ranges are based on the general
population and needs will be different
for every person
some people like long-distance runners
for example are going to need much
higher intakes of carbs in order to
build up sufficient glycogen stores then
for example somebody who's sitting at a
desk all day other people may feel that
they have more stable energy when they
eat more
protein and fat and a little less carbs
this helps explain why different people
thrive on different ways of eating some
youtube fruitarians for example
apparently do really really well on a
super super high carb diet even though
we would never recommend this for the
general population while other youtubers
may thrive on a really low carb meat
only diet
these may be extremes that we don't
recommend to the public for a lot of
reasons but if that's what truly feels
good to that particular person then cool
keep in mind that these AMDR ranges are
pretty broad and in some cases may be
more flexible than others so for example
to be below the AMDR for protein or fat
would probably have more health concerns
associated with it compared to being a
little bit on the low end for carbs just
given what we know about keto for
example but when i make suggestions on
these what i in a day videos i'm
speaking more to the general population
who's watching not necessarily to that
unique extreme diet of a single youtuber
now if you remember in my video on
principle number four i talked about the
food anthropologist this is a
non-judgmental voice that helps you make
observations about your eating if you
notice that you feel better when you eat
a certain way even if it's not perfectly
aligned with the AMD RS you would be
eating intuitively because you're just
listening to what your body wants
however it becomes unintuitive depending
on your intention if your intention is
to manipulate your body and it feels
restrictive then this is not intuitive
eating so for example if i tried to
follow a carnivore or a fruitarian diet
i would be dying for an apple or an egg
respectively most of us enjoy and thrive
on some degree of balance even if the
macronutrient distribution is not
perfect again intuitive eating is all
about listening to your body and finally
what works best for you in a
non-judgmental non restrictive way if
you naturally enjoy eating protein rich
or fabrics boots that is fine the key is
to give yourself permission
to Joy carbs if you're in the mood for
them to now on that note let's move on
to today's video so in today's video
we're gonna be discussing principle
number seven cope with your emotions
without using food now if I were to
pinpoint one of the biggest challenges
for people on their intuitive eating
journey it will probably be learning how
to deal with the trials and tribulations
of life without resorting to food as
their only coping mechanism let's be
honest not every day is going to be
sunshine and rainbows as humans we
experience an array of emotions like
anger happiness boredom loneliness
anxiety and so on and experiencing these
emotions is completely normal and just
part of being human we can't always
change or control that but we'll be can
control is how we process and cope with
our emotions for most people food has
deep emotional significance a cup of
coffee and they remind us of energy and
the start to a great day so much so that
even my decaf cup sometimes perks me up
to a chicken pot pie may remind us of
that time you spend with your
grandmother and a slice of cake may be
our way to celebrate a birthday or
hallmark occasion you may also use food
as a coping mechanism so for example
eating a pint of ice cream is a classic
rom-com response to a heartbreak or
squirting cheese spray into your mouth
when you were bored on the couch
Hollywood sure knows how to portray
emotions and food because as humans we
all just naturally cope with food the
thing is from the day we are born we
Swart our emotions with food think about
a crying baby that just won't stop you
pop a boob or a bottle in the mouth
hoping that it might shut up as a kid
our parents our grandparents give us a
popsicle to pacify us if we scrape our
knee or were bullied at school food is a
sign of love it's used as comfort it's
used as reward so often in our society
and in some cases it may also seem like
the only reliable friend that you have
in times of sadness or loneliness when
life is really looking hard reaching for
delicious food is very
common and a way to feel some type of
enjoyment in a sea of hard times even if
that enjoyment is fleeting and temporary
unfortunately it may not be obvious to
you that you're spawning this way to
your emotions I mean you may eat the bag
of chips but not realize that you're
using it as an outlet in fact I
encourage you next time you're eating to
ask yourself why am i eating this right
now in a lot of cases it may not be
because you're physically hungry it's
because you're emotionally hungry
or maybe you're bored and you want to
keep your hands busy which is also what
we call mouth hunger either way one of
the potential outcomes of using food in
response to emotions is overeating
interestingly the after effect of
emotional eating is well new emotions I
hear people say all the time I feel
guilty because I ate X Y & Z but here's
the thing
guilt is associated with a moral
wrongdoing and food isn't morally right
or wrong it's just food unless you stole
the food or committed some type of crime
to get it there's nothing to feel guilty
about however although responding to
your emotions with food may lead to a
minor dopamine response that feels good
research has shown that this type of
behavior can actually negatively affect
our emotions shortly after so although
you shouldn't feel guilty about enjoying
food if you're noticing that you're
eating to cope with emotions it may not
fix the root of the problem there are
many ways that we use food to cope with
our feelings all of which have unique
outcomes and lay on a continuum from
satisfaction to numbing so first a
sensory gratification as mentioned in my
last video on principle number six food
provides pleasure and this is a good
thing without pleasure food would be
incredibly boring and unenjoyable and
evolutionarily speaking we wouldn't try
very hard to get it when we find
satisfaction in the foods that we eat
we're much less likely to overeat if
you're choosing to eat certain foods
because you enjoy them this is natural
and a normal part of eating next is
comfort certain foods just bring us
comfort at different times in our lives
chicken soup is a classic sick meal for
a reason it's warm easy and super
comforting curling up in a blanket on
the couch and sipping hot chocolate is
also so relaxing and calming choosing
comfort foods is normal and it's
actually a part of having a really
healthy relationship with food provided
that you don't feel guilty after eating
or drinking it in fact diet culture has
co-opted the idea of comfort foods to be
associated with a lack of nutrition when
in fact what brings you comfort could in
fact be truly nourishing however it's
important to note that we can abuse food
as a coping mechanism if it's our only
tool in our toolbox we want to enjoy
food and have it bring us comfort but
not to have it solve all of our problems
next is distraction food can be used to
distract us from reality or feelings
that we don't want to necessarily
experience using food this way it can be
harmful because it prevents us from
being able to detect our body's natural
emotions and signals it also stops you
from identifying the source of your
feelings and really getting to the root
of your needs if you consistently turn
to a bag of chips and binge watch
Netflix for hours to distract you from a
stressful day it might be time to find
other ways of managing your emotions
keep in mind we are human and these
things are going to happen every now and
again but if you're finding yourself
turning to food to shield your emotions
on a regular basis it's probably
something that we need to address we
want to learn to be present with our
food not use it as a distraction from
our life next to sedation things become
concerning when we start to use food as
a way to numb our feelings some people
like to call this a food coma because it
involves eating to the point where you
don't notice your feelings your hunger
or really anything anymore you're
basically on autopilot this type of
eating is very common in people who feel
like their lives are attica
troll and use food as a way to
completely mute what's going on in
severe cases this can lead to social
isolation missing work or feeling
completely hopeless about life hunger
and satiety cues are usually completely
ignored or not noticed and this can lead
to spiraling out of control with our
overeating next is punishment now for
those of you who use food as a form of
sedation this can lead to self blame and
punishing behaviors in severe cases some
people may overeat to the point where
they feel super sick in order to punish
themselves this severe form of emotional
eating can be detrimental to self esteem
and result in complete self-hatred
typically those who punish themselves
with food report no enjoyment from food
whatsoever and in fact say that they
hate food for this type of severe eating
compassion and understanding is really
important which comes from the nurturer
voice that I talked about in principle
number four moreover seeking
professional help from a psychologist
and a dietician may also be really
helpful okay now that we have an
understanding of the ways people cope
with food let's dive into why people
emotionally eat a lot of people are not
even aware that they're eating
emotionally and just kind of brush it
off as well it tastes good
but as an intuitive eater if you openly
accept all foods then they're always
available this means that even if the
food tastes good you can stop at any
time because it'll be available the next
time that you want it chances are that
it'll actually taste even better when
you're actually hungry for it if you're
still eating after you're full I want
you to ask yourself if my body feels
satisfied after eating a certain amount
of food but I still continue to eat
after I'm full
what other need am I trying to resolve
with this food you may realize that
you're using food to address some other
major feelings so let's go over some of
the major ones first is boredom and
procrastination this is probably one of
the most common reasons for eating so
for example you might be watching your
daily soaps and
turn to a snack or maybe you're waiting
for a friend to kind of pick you up and
you're snacking on candy while you wait
in these cases you're not eating because
you're hungry but rather because you're
entertaining yourself with food next is
bribery and reward throw out our lives
we've probably used food as a reward or
even as a bribe to get somebody to do
something for example you may tell your
kids that they can pick out a chocolate
bar if they behave while your shop or
maybe you reward yourself with a
doughnut for doing a really hard workout
while there is nothing wrong with
enjoying foods in good times using food
as a reward can actually be
self-perpetuating there are always going
to be things in your life to reward
yourself for and there will always be
times when your kids need to behave
trust me
using food as the solution creates an
expectation that food will always be the
reward or bribe for certain good
behaviors next is excitement one of the
reasons that people like to go on diets
is because they can trigger feelings of
excitement and hope this diet is going
to be the one it's that newness that
really excites people and motivates them
to get started
doing something that let's be real they
don't actually really want to do over
time we do tend to get bored of the same
old food same old life and want to just
inherently mix things up problem is
using food as a way to add excitement to
your life usually leads to feelings of
despair when that diet stops working
that excitement turns to upset and leads
you to use food again in order to cope
then you try a new diet it's exciting at
first stops working you cope as you can
see this creates a bit of a cycle that
is really hard to break next is soothing
so using candy as a way to add sweetness
to your life is a temporary fix to a
much larger problem although food of
course can bring out really good
feelings if you're finding yourself
constantly using eating to incite
relaxation or happiness this can involve
into a poor relationship with food
next is love anger and stress food can
be used as a way to express love so for
example making a meal for your partner
can be a way to show them that you
appreciate them and that you care about
them it can also be a way to express
anger so for example turning to really
crunchy chips to physically chomp down
on something is commonly used as a way
to relieve anger or just to annoy your
husband like I often do anyways finally
food can be used or not used to deal
with stress during acute stress there is
a rush of adrenaline known as the
fight-or-flight response which was
designed to help us run away from
threats this occurs more with acute
stress meaning that in Stemper Airy
problem is the stress of the experience
tends to be chronic stress which raises
our cortisol levels and can lead to
extra storage of abdominal fat if you
compound this with stress eating this
often leads people into overeating and
to the idea of blowing your diet which
in itself causes stress that perpetuates
the cycle next is a sense of connection
whether you belong to a religious group
sports team or other organization
feeling a part of a group is a really
important part of human survival if
going in for wings after a game is a
routine for your sports team I mean you
may feel inclined to eat even if you're
not really hungry instead of feeling
like a diet Debbie that everyone is
gonna nag you may just eat anyway and
feel dissatisfied or just like really
uncomfortably full this is really common
for people who want to bond with others
but struggle to find a way to manage
social eating situations and their
actual unique needs alright so now that
we have an idea of how and why people
emotionally eat
how can you cope with your emotions
without using food well the first thing
that I want you to try is to ask
yourself four important questions in a
four step process am I actually hungry
if yes then my all means honor your
hunger and eat if not then answer the
next question what am I feeling if
you're not biologically hungry then what
are you hungry for what are you feeling
for most people this isn't something
that's really easy to pinpoint so I
would suggest trying one of the
following use a journal and write out
your feelings and emotions chat with a
friend to vent sit in a quiet room and
let yourself experience these feelings
you might be really surprised how much
this can help or seek out some
professional help from a counselor or
psychologist once you've determined this
you can move on to the next question and
that is what do I need in a lot of cases
people eat to fulfill an unmet need so
for example you might find yourself
turning to candy and sweets after work
every day even if you're not actually
hungry after diving into how you're
feeling you might notice that you feel
burnt out and really tired instead of
food what you likely need is some rest
and sleep so to solve this problem
focusing on sleep hygiene may be a good
first step to do this it's time to move
to step 4 and that may mean asking for a
little bit of support if you notice that
you're really burnt out finding time for
yourself may be really hard to do but
it's so essential to breaking the cycle
of emotional eating
whether it's your boss or your partner
asking for time for yourself may be
really helpful for example ask your boss
for a personal day or ask your partner
to watch the kids for 45 minutes while
you take a bath or go to a yoga class
uninterrupted time to yourself may help
meet your actual needs for relaxation
and also help you realize that food must
not the solution to your problem in the
first place there are many ways that
people can meet their needs without food
and this will ultimately be very
different for each individual person
with that being said there are some
basic needs that almost everyone needs
that do not involve food and that is
rest sensual pleasure ability to express
one's self and feelings be heard
understood and accepted being stimulated
both intellectually and creatively and
comfort and warmth
if these needs are not met you may turn
to food in order to cope and while it
may be easy for some it can be really
hard for a lot of other people just to
meet these basic needs Evelyn Tribble
Ian
should give some really great
suggestions for dealing with your
feelings in their book one write in a
journal and express your true feelings
to talk to a friend on the phone or in
person if you're like me you may want to
maybe talk to a few record yourself on
your phone this man should be really
helpful if no one is available at the
moment so that you can have a bit of a
conversation with yourself to kind of
hash things out for physically express
your feelings in a safe way like maybe
punching a bag or a pillow confront the
person who is upsetting you if you're
feeling safe to do so
cry as much as you want I mean it is
very natural and it is a healthy way to
deal with grief anger sadness etc sit
and let yourself discover your feelings
and emotions seek out professional help
this is actually not a last resort and
it's actually something that I recommend
everybody try to access if they can and
finally engage in some acts of self-care
so some popular acts of self-care that
you can utilize in your journey include
meditation reading a book relaxing on
the couch taking a sauna or a hot tub if
you can listening to music playing games
with friends family or a pet taking a
relaxing bath getting a massage going
for a walk or some other form of
physical activity and asking someone for
a hug the human hug is one of the most
profound but helpful ways to cope it
actually releases a cascade of feel-good
chemicals that can be calming relaxing
and provide support if you don't have
someone to hug at the moment even
hugging a stuffed animal or a real
animal can be really helpful my personal
outlet is exercise I know such a
dietician thing to say but I'm not
talking about doing like a CrossFit
session or sprinting on the treadmill
for 90 minutes no thank you
even just going for a walk with my
toddler or my husband can absolutely
help research has found that exercise
and other healthy coping mechanisms can
be a really effective way to manage
stress and emotional eating so exercise
in particular provides a healthy
distraction from your stress while also
providing a boost of endorphins and an
outlet
that can ultimately help to relieve
stress as you navigate this principle I
want to emphasize that you may deal with
some discomfort for a while after a
lifetime of using food to cope with your
emotions it may be really overwhelming
to experience your emotions and your
feelings up close it's actually
completely okay to enjoy foods flavors
and the feelings that we get from it
this is healthy but we really want to
get away from using these experiences to
fill a void or cover up underlying
problems that you're facing as I've said
throughout the series intuitive eating
is not a straight road you are going to
have times when you eat emotionally and
that is perfectly fine the goal is to
identify emotional eating and navigate
the reason behind it
in some ways having this setback may
actually help you realize how far you've
really come you may notice that you find
it easier to identify the reasons for
your emotional eating and find
appropriate outlets it may also be a
clue
that you need to reassess your current
life situation if you're eating because
you're angry look into what is causing
that anger if you're eating because
you're tired or bored what can you do to
solve that by being a food
anthropologist you can start to identify
trends in your behavior and begin to
connect them to situations in your real
life so instead of feeling out of
control appreciate that you've developed
the skills to do this and identify the
problem early before it gets completely
out of control as you continue through
your intuitive eating journey remember
that food is something that we should
all enjoy and use to nourish our body
and our mind your relationship with food
will become so much stronger when you
use food for a pleasurable experience
rather than just as a way to cope so for
this week I want you to identify the
reasons for your emotional eating using
the four steps or questions can be
really super helpful am I actually
hungry what am I feeling what do I need
and can I have some support in addition
to this I wanted to find at least one
non-food coping mechanism that
feels good to you so for example see if
exercise helps to relieve your stress or
maybe you like dealing with stress by
reading a book whatever it is find
something that you genuinely find
relaxing if you reach for food try doing
this first if you're still wanting food
after this then assess whether you're
eating emotionally or if you're actually
hungry again this may take time to learn
how to do but over time you will have a
much easier experience identifying the
reasons behind your food choices I want
to of course a flag that it is
absolutely okay to be eating for
emotional reasons the key is to identify
these reasons to be accepting of them to
be compassionate with yourself and to
move on and to not let those food
choices inform the rest of your day the
rest of your week the rest of your month
and your general effect so continue to
work on all of these steps throughout
your intuitive eating journey and stay
tuned for our next video on principle
number 8 respect your body alright folks
that's all for today don't forget to
give this video the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you have any questions
about intuitive eating subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]
you